isn't it amazing how you've always
maintained your voice now listen you had
you were infamous you had your drug days
and you were wild on you know i mean
when you were a young man you were a
[ __ ] maniac right
you were a [ __ ] maniac and yet you
came through it healthy i assume right
yep and the voice is still good the only
way out is through you know i was uh
you know humongous to die for a drug
addict i still
you know i have a couple puffs off my
girlfriend's cigarette and it's like
whoa um but you know i keep it in check
right i know i got a 12-step thing i do
you know and i how cool would it be to
be the guy who like you check in with
when you feel like you're going to go
back to drugs like isn't don't you have
like a sponsor
you know what i work with i work with
betty ford and i work with uh um a bunch
of people do you can i be i'm like a
patient advocate
uh where they'll call me up just kind of
like
oh we have a runner yeah and they'll
just say look i can get stephen on the
phone and [ __ ] no way and so i
talked to him okay i got to talk him off
the ledge and i just i tell him how what
i go first what drugs you take right
what did you take what did you abuse how
did you get caught up in it
and i tell them you know it doesn't
matter i did the same thing right but
i'm out the rabbit hole
are you oh yeah do you feel confident
that you'll never go back to using
anything that i don't you don't i keep
myself honest with i'm just
a hit record away
do you have right are you in other words
if you had a big huge record right
that's what used to do it now i'm i'm
locked in like i said you go to 12 step
once a week you're golden when you
remind you of where you used to be
and you're back and you know when you
say you're a hit record away in other
words when you would have a monster hit
did that in a way
make you nervous like oh how am i going
to keep this going and then you turn to
drugs to relax you conversely it's like
it would be like uh they said in rehab
the first rehab you know
you're sober now what if your mom and
dad die
right how are you what if something
happens to your kids what if what are
you going to do first thing you're going
to reach for because we're americans the
john wayne yeah give me a hint of
courage right it's what we do and
everyone's
you know
it's so hard to survive in this world it
is
america everywhere that people want a
little release i don't blame people for
getting high i took it to the wall and i
got a talent god-given talent i got so
stoned i lost it i lost it all